هذه المشاهد لن تكون الوحيده في موسكو بل
سيعتاد الروس على رؤيتها في قادم الايام
يقول هؤلاء او ما يعرف بفيلق روسيا الحره
مقاتلون روس تدعمهم
المجموعه التي باتت تظهر عقب كل هجوم داخل
الاراضي الروسيه تتوعد بتكثيف الضربات في
الداخل الروسي عقب اكتمال استعداداتها
فوفقا لقائد المجموعه المعروف باسم قيصر
فان الاف من المتطوعين ينتظرون الانضمام
الى مجموعته تحضيرا لمواصله هجماتهم ضد
اهداف داخل روسيا بما فيها العاصمه موسكو
يقول الرجل ان وحدته بقوه كتيبه والتي
عاده ما تتكون من 500 الى الف جندي ولديهم
خطط للتوسع على الارض واخرى لزياده القوات
من اجل القيام بما سماه حمله الكرملين
ترفض المجموعه وصفها بالعصابه او شركه
عسكريه مثل فاجنر بل كونهم معارضه روسيه
مسلحه تريد تحرير بلدها كما تقول تقول
المجموعه انها تقف وراء الهجوم الاخيره
على موسكو بالطائرات المسيره والهدف منه
هو دعمه هجوم اوكرانيا المضاد وبمثابه حمل
التجنيد لتشجيع الروس على الاطاحه
وفقا لصحيفه التايمز فان قائد المجموعه
قومي روسي وكان عضوا في مجموعتين يمينيتين
تم تصنيفهما كمنظمات ارهابيه بتهمه التامر
ضد الكرملين وان الاخيره شن حمله قمع ضد
الحركه القوميه منذ اكثر من عقد في محاوله
لوقف شعبياتها المتزايده التي يرجح ان
بوتين كان ينظر اليها على انها تهديد
محتمل لحكمه تهديد يبدو انه عاد للظهور
مجددا وبشكل
مختلف
تقارير الاخ
باري لا تنسوا الاشتراك
في يوتيوب الضغط على زر الاعجاب وتفعيل
جرس التنبيهات